- How y'all doing?
(audience responds)
All right, I'm glad three of you're good.
That makes me happy.
How y'all doing?
(audience responds)
All right, there we go. There we go.
I'm so excited here, we started early.
It's not even time yet,
but we did it 'cause we're excited.
My name is Eric Johnson, and
I'm super happy to be here.
I'm a principal developer advocate at AWS.
And let's get our,
we're gonna slip our
slide on here real quick.
There we go.
All right, now we're
seeing what we should see.
And Matt, introduce yourself.
- Hey, everybody, my name's Matt.
I'm part of the specialist
team here at AWS.
I'm a container specialist.
I spend most of my time
helping customers build cool,
exciting, interesting
architectures with ECS and Lambda
and all of our cool
auto mode technologies.
- I have to be honest, I'm super
thrilled to talk with Matt.
Matt and I have got to
travel a lot together.
I have now learned to say
his last name properly.
It's Meckes, not Meeks.
At least that's what he tells me.
- Almost, almost.
- I nailed it, didn't I? Yeah.
So how many of y'all have
heard me speak before?
Oh, ooh, a good room.
Okay, do you know the rules?
All right, a couple of you know the rules.
Mark out here knows the rules, all right.
Well, for those of you
who don't know the rules,
do you know the rules?
- I don't know the rules, Eric.
- Okay, well, here's the rules.
So when I'm speaking, rules
is probably a strong word,
but you know, it'll
really help you kind of,
as we go through today, because
I like to have a lot of fun.
But these are the rules, all right?
There's three of them.
Okay, the first is,
this is any number I want it to be, okay?
Now, I'm gonna hold this
up and I'm gonna say,
"There's three rules," okay?
And someone who comes in
late is gonna be like,
"That's not a three."
Well, it is because
that's the rule, right?
Okay, the second is, these
are quotes, not apostrophes.
And I know that, okay?
'Cause this looks dumb, okay?
So I do this, right?
And finally, these are thumbs
'cause this will get
you beat up, all right?
So those are the three
rules, and that helps a lot.
I do like to make a lot
of one-fingered jokes.
I will make jokes as
we're going through today.
I'm very comfortable. I was born this way.
I didn't wake up this way for
the first time this morning.
I did wake up this way,
but not for the first time this morning.
But again, I'm very comfortable with that.
However, if that makes you uncomfortable,
I'm also comfortable with that.
So I'm good.
And we'll have a good time today.
Super happy you're here.
Matt and I have been working through this,
excited about this deck.
How many of y'all are using,
by the way, if you're
not familiar with y'all,
that's everybody in the room.
So that's a Texas thing. So there you go.
There's all y'all too.
So how many of you all are using ECS now?
Oh, okay, all righty, good.
How many of y'all are doing
event-driven architectures
with ECS?
Well, why are you here?
(audience laughing)
All right, so you wanna
learn how to do it better?
Okay, we really gotta,
we gotta meet the bar.
- Gave my-
- Yeah, exactly, all right.
Just a lot of pressure on us to hit this.
So that's what we're gonna
be talking about today,
is event-driven architectures,
but using Amazon ECS with AWS Fargate.
And that may not be the
first thing you think about.
You may not go, "Ah, yeah,
EDA, we think Fargate,
we think ECS."
But it's a very viable solution today.
We're gonna talk through that.
All right, you ready?
- Let's go.
- Here we go.
All right, we wanna introduce
you to a buddy of ours.
This is Sarah.
Now, I know we've all been,
how many, let me ask you this.
How many of y'all are developers?
Okay, how many of y'all dabble with code
but don't claim to be a developer?
All right, so you're a developer.
Stop hinging on that, all right?
So if you dabble with code,
you're developer, right?
This is Sarah.
Sarah runs a midsize
development team, right?
And they use ECS.
They primarily use ECS,
and they love ECS and
they love Sarah, right?
And here we are, and we've all been there.
This time, it's November 27th.
Do we have the dates
right? That might be wrong.
Do I change that? We'll see.
Anyway, it's Black Friday.
Maybe I have the dates
wrong. We'll see on that.
But it's Black Friday.
It's late in the evening.
Anybody been watching their architecture
right before Black Friday?
If you haven't, you haven't
been a developer long, right?
I've been that developer
in the middle of the night,
and you're watching,
you're good, you're solid,
things are looking okay,
maybe there's a little
hiccup, but we're okay.
And then all of a
sudden, 10 minutes later,
everything falls apart, right?
10 minutes after you drop a brand new SKU,
something exciting is coming out.
Your system can't handle it.
And this is where Sarah's at,
and we've all been there
at 3:30 in the morning.
If you haven't had your
head on a desk crying,
you're not a developer, right?
Or put your head through a wall, right?
So we've all been there.
But here's the truth, okay?
This isn't an ECS problem,
it's an architectural problem, right?
If you don't know who that is, that's me.
So I don't, or Matt, it
really could be Matt too.
Really, it's just a beard that
makes a difference, right?
So what went wrong?
If you think about this, what went wrong?
Well, like so many people,
when Sarah built her architecture,
she built it using
synchronous microservices.
Now, microservices are
a good thing, right?
We hear that all the time.
Microservices, small, you know,
independent services
that are run together.
We love that.
But the synchronous part can
kind of get us into trouble.
And why is that?
Well, when we make that
order and we hit the discount
and everything's good,
the next thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna check our loyalty.
And, oh no, our loyalty blew up.
So what happens is the
whole thing kind of fizzles
and falls apart
because we've tightly
coupled this architecture,
and it's all kind of
dependent on each other.
And this probably isn't
news to a lot of you, right?
You're like, "Oh, yeah,
yeah, I've seen this before."
But you might have some
architecture this way.
Anybody responsible for that old 1988 code
that's built like this, right?
I've been there, right?
And so it's like, "Well,
how do we fix this?" Right?
So in reality, Sarah
needs a different way.
So when we say a different way,
you know, let's look at
the synchronous model
and see kind of why we wanna change that.
So you think about synchronous
response and request models,
or request response models, you think,
"Well, these are good," right?
They've got some advantages,
they're low latency,
they're very fast, right?
It's simple.
Yeah, anybody can build a
synchronous microservice, right?
And it fails fast.
It's very often,
or it's not very often
that we like to fail,
but when we're gonna fail,
we want it to fail fast
and we want it to fail
in development, right?
So that's a good thing.
But there are some pretty big
disadvantages to this as well,
ones that are worth probably looking
at getting out of it, right?
'Cause the first is we
can get throttling, right?
And so when you build these out,
your producer, it needs to
know about your consumers.
And as it's going
through, it gets complex.
It can get throttled because
it can't send everything.
Or maybe your consumer gets throttled
'cause it can't handle everything.
And then you get resiliency issues,
and you have problems on Black Friday
at 3:30 in the morning,
and that's where you're at.
So how do you fix that?
Well, that's what we're
gonna talk about today,
and we're gonna talk about
that in relation to, you know,
running microservices and
running things on ECS.
Now, how do we think you should do this?
But really, and that
this is gonna be a little
oversimplified, but it really
comes down to not using,
or synchronous microservices, right?
It comes down to,
what we like to do is insert
a broker of subtype, right?
Where we wanna say,
rather than in that previous model
where the producer talks to the consumer
and the consumer responds to the producer,
instead, we're gonna put a broker in.
Now, this broker is a very kind
of just a term we're using.
I'm not picking a specific one.
We'll actually get into
that in a little bit.
But this is the idea of
something's in the middle
and their entire job's to go,
"Hey, I got your request.
Have a good day."
And then the consumer either
through polling, pulling,
or pushing or any different
kind of models will say,
"Hey, give me that."
Or, "Hey, thank you for that."
And I'll acknowledge.
And maybe they acknowledge to the broker,
maybe they acknowledge back to the client.
There's different patterns,
we'll look at that.
But this idea of having
something in the middle
to help break these apart
and decouple the producer
from the consumer is where we get
into a lot more flexibility
and reliability, right?
So we're talking about this idea
in what we call event-driven architecture.
Now, let's look at what does
event-driven architecture mean.
I'm gonna read this to you.
Event-driven architecture,
EDA is a distributed computing
paradigm implementing
asynchronous message-passing semantics
through intermediary message brokers,
enabling temporal and spatial decoupling
of system components via
non-blocking I/O operations
and persistent event storage.
You can go.
I've given you all you need to know.
Anybody understand that?
I intentionally had Claude
give me a complex explanation
because sometimes DA is a mystery to us.
We look at it and go,
"Oh, that's scary stuff."
But in reality,
I'm gonna give you a more
technical definition of EDA.
And if you were ever
gonna write something down
or take a picture, this is the time,
because this is gonna get super technical.
I might have to do it a couple times.
So let me explain EDA to you.
You ready?
Matt still doesn't understand this,
but I'll give it to you, all right?
- [Matt] I'm getting that later.
- Okay, yeah, all right.
So here's a less technical,
but it's still technical
definition of EDA.
Something happens
and we respond.
We react, I got it wrong.
We're gonna do it again.
Did everybody get that?
Let's try it again.
Something happens
and we react.
That's EDA.
Yes, that's oversimplified.
And yes, it's a little tongue in cheek,
but it's the idea of,
rather than our consumers
going, "What are you doing?
What are you doing? What are you doing?
What are you doing? What are you doing?"
Or our producer's going,
"Here's what I'm doing.
Here's what I'm doing.
Here's what I'm doing."
And the logic getting very
coupled, we're able to say,
"Let's break that apart
and make them kind of,
you know, decoupled from each other."
So what does that look like?
Well, here in the, before EDA,
we have this producer, is
talking to the consumers,
and the producer needs to know
about each of these
consumers, needs to know,
"Hey, who's consuming my data?
And, you know, and so it
needs to send to each one.
So if something happens,
it's gonna send to the consumer one,
send to consumer two,
send to consumer three.
We kind of saw this pattern already.
So let's throw in a broker,
some kind of broker.
And we break this down and we say,
"Okay, now instead, I'm
gonna just send out an event.
And I don't care what happens after that."
I mean, overall, and,
you know, metaphorically
and allegorically, I don't
even know the right words.
We care, but the producer doesn't care.
It just says, "Hey, I did
my job. Here's an event.
Whoever consumes it, do it."
And so these consumers go,
"Okay, yeah, I want that.
I want that. I want that."
And so there's some benefits to this.
When we build this out and we say,
"Okay, we're gonna break these apart,"
it gives us the ability
to build very scalable
applications, right?
And so we're able to build bigger
because we're not so tightly coupled.
It also gives us resilience, right?
So if consumer A goes down,
consumer B is still chugging along.
If there's some dependency on each other,
we can handle that.
But they can handle that gracefully.
We can degrade gracefully, right?
And finally, it gives us a lot of agility.
When you build this way,
rather than constantly
updating that producer
to send it to, "Hey, you
need to know more logic
to talk to these consumers."
We need to then, all we do
is we add another consumer
and say, "I'll consume that as well."
So we can do that unbeknownst,
that was a big word.
That was almost a
British word right there.
Unbeknownst to the producer,
we can do that, right?
This is a really cool pattern.
However, here's the catch.
Like so many of you,
Sarah's asking the question,
"How do we go from
synchronous microservices
to event-driven architecture?"
And that's why we're here today, right?
So I'm gonna turn it
over to my buddy, Matt,
and Matt's gonna walk
you through some of this,
and we'll be talking about some things.
- So I think this is often
when someone like me gets involved.
So you've got a customer
who's had a major problem,
they want to make some
sort of transformation
or modernization.
And we've gotta think about, you know,
what's the kind of mental
model we're gonna use
to go through this journey
from kind of monolithic
synchronous services to EDA?
I like to think of three real buckets
of kind of categories of
questions we wanna think about.
First, we've got our business logic.
So the actual stuff that we
care about as developers,
the stuff we've wrote, we've
gotta run that somewhere.
So we gotta think about
what's our compute.
Eric talked about event routers,
and he just, you know, put a
kind of a nice green circle
in his diagram and said,
"Hey, we've now decoupled."
There's a lot more subtlety to that.
So we've really gotta think about
what event routers are we going to use?
What are the trade-offs?
What are the patterns that we can apply?
And then we've gotta take those components
and we've gotta combine them
into all of these architectural
patterns and blueprints
that we wanna do at scale.
Because whilst something
happens, we react to it.
It's really, really simple on that side.
Actually, there's a lot of subtlety
that actually within the category
of event-driven architectures,
there's a whole bunch of quite
precise subpatterns we can
use that have their own
trade offs and complexities.
And we wanna kind of codify those
so we can use them at
scale across organization,
baking best practice into what we do.
So first off, we've got
some options around compute.
And I think that one of
the really common things
that I see customers do when
they come out of a big outage
and your CTO is, you know,
"Hey, we built this modern
microservices thing,
we're running on ECS,
and we still went down."
They kind of throw the
baby out with a bath water.
We're gonna throw this away
and we're gonna refactor to Lambda
because we've seen that
Lambda is scalable.
And Lambda always, you
know, AWS takes care of it.
And we don't have to think about it.
You know, that's, you know,
Lambda's great at scaling,
but yeah, you can still, with
bad architectural patterns,
get yourself caught into some dead ends.
Or let's throw away this ECS thing.
What we, if we move to Kubernetes
and the Kubernetes ecosystem,
maybe we can solve all of our problems
with this technology change
and, you know, that's gonna be
more scalable, more powerful.
Look at all this cool open
source things that we can buy
and we can use this whole ISV ecosystem.
Well, actually, you
know, I'd like to propose
that when you are going through
a big architectural change,
you wanna really focus on the
bits where you can add value,
and you probably don't wanna
change everything at once.
If you're changing programming language,
don't change architectural pattern.
If you're changing architectural pattern,
maybe don't change your compute.
You know, so limit
yourself to the sort of a,
a set of things that you can change.
And also, we want to go
on an incremental journey.
We don't wanna say,
"Hey, we're gonna spend the
next year building a brand new
platform that's gonna be
ready in early November.
So when Black Friday comes around,
we can throw a big
switching underneath them.
We want to make a series of changes.
Every week, we're
iterating towards this path
over the next year.
So when our next big sale
comes on, we're ready.
So my hypothesis, let's go and do this.
Let's stay on ECS
and let's see how we
can build this with ECS
'cause we're gonna make a whole bunch
of other interesting changes.
A little bit of info about what ECS is,
I think we got a lot of
hands raised in the room,
so I won't belabor the point too much,
but I think it's a pretty
cool service run by AWS
that allows you to deploy, run,
launch containers at scale,
does a whole bunch of optimizations
behind the scenes for you
so you can focus on
delivering business value.
And customers tend to agree.
So something like three
billion Amazon ECS tasks
are launched every week,
which is just like a
completely wild number.
A really interesting one
that I really like is that
when people start building
with containers,
the majority of them
start building with ECS.
So it's a really, really common pattern.
When you're using the ECS control plane,
there's a couple of options
with your data plane.
You could use Fargate,
our kind of serverless data plane
where you just define your
tasks and your services,
and we'll manage that compute for you.
We have a isolated workload model
where you get kind of strong tenancy,
and you only can pay for the
compute that you're using.
However, you know, we
are making some choices,
and on your behalf, we think
they're sensible choices,
but they're not the right
choices in every case.
You can also bring your own data plane.
So you can say, "I want
these specific instance types
in this size and I'm gonna
manage scaling them out."
And Fargate is gonna go and run
them on those EC2 instances.
One of the big re:Invent
releases a couple of weeks ago
was ECS Managed Instances.
I'll do another little poll in the room.
Who's seen the ECS
Managed Instances release
in the last few weeks?
Has anyone heard of it?
A few hands,
but it's pretty early still.
ECS Managed Instances and
the Lambda Managed Instances
that was launched last night are really,
really interesting models
where you can bring your own
data plane of EC2 instances,
but AWS does all the management
of those instances on your behalf.
So we'll do all the patching, OS patching,
management of those instances.
You can just define what
instance types you want to use.
And so you get a lot of the benefits
of using that kind of flexibility
that I want a specific
Graviton instance in my fleet
because I've worked at
my Java code runs best
on those instances.
But you don't have all of that overhead.
It's also got a really
interesting modification
to the capacity provider.
That means it scales faster
than your own EC2 instance fleet,
which is really, really cool.
So that moves the shared
responsibility a little bit.
So instead of having to think
about your own auto-scaling
and launch templates and
availability distribution
and instance selection, you
can hand it over to AWS,
you can define the instances that you want
in your task templates
and we'll take care of it,
and you can get all the
benefits of your savings plans
and all the kind of capacity
planning, et cetera.
However, it doesn't mean that
Fargate isn't still the kind
of default way that people
are building on ECS,
and I think that most
people should probably start
with the most serverless option,
which is Fargate and only breakout
if they've got more complex requirements.
So we've chosen ECS.
We're gonna continue running on Fargate.
We think that's still a sensible option.
There are a couple of different models
when you are running with ECS.
The first thing is running
with a standalone task.
So with a standalone
task, something happens.
We get to run a task event.
And the Fargate service goes,
"Okay, great, something's
happened, let's react."
So we're gonna go and
provision some compute
to deal with that event.
And we're gonna take
some time provisioning.
So we'll go through provisioning state.
We're then gonna go and run that task.
So we're gonna do some running.
And then afterwards, we're
gonna get that container
and we're gonna throw it away,
stop it, and not reuse it.
Now, that's a really, really
good pattern, really powerful,
but it is newing up a container
to run each of your events.
So it's not really appropriate
if you are sending thousands of events.
We're trying to do our Black Friday sale.
We've got thousand orders a second coming
into our eCommerce store.
We don't wanna be using
this model for that.
It's gonna get us into some trouble.
We also have this other model
where we can run as a service.
So this is, we can define some compute.
So we're gonna say we want a vCPU,
we want a couple of gigs of ram.
We want to have at least four copies,
and we wanna scale that out
with some scale parameters.
And Eric's gonna talk about some
of the metrics you can
use to scale out later.
And so we're gonna go
and build a target group
that that's gonna be running.
And actually, we can think
about how we can send events
to that kind of statically stable compute
and how it's gonna scale out.
And Eric will go into some
more details around that.
So we've got these kind of big patterns.
And, you know, my hypothesis
is these are really powerful,
really useful characteristics to use
when we're building EDA.
We've got scalability.
We can have kind of target tracking.
We can build all sorts of
interesting target tracking
with custom metrics.
Containers and microservices
and these kind of patterns
are very comfortable together.
And because it's an AWS managed service,
it has native integrations
with all of the building blocks we use
to build event-driven architectures.
Things like step functions, EventBridge,
even SQS and SNS all
play very, very nicely
with EventBridge.
And you can use all of those
things like managed instances
and Savings Plans and Spot
to make sure that you're
getting the best price
for your compute and the
best total cost of ownership.
So settled on some compute.
Our next big category of questions is
what event brokers are we going to use?
What routers are we gonna use?
And so our first category
of brokers are routers.
Routers are a pattern
where the router processes
one event at a time.
You can point that event at
multiple targets and protocols.
So it's a one to many pattern.
You're building logic at the router,
so you can build rules and filtering rules
and targets at the router.
So you've got quite a
smart, sophisticated router
that's doing a whole
bunch of work for you.
And that means that the router
can handle things like retry,
dead-letter queues, error handling,
even things like throttling
and rate limiting.
So it's a pretty smart router,
which means that it's really simple
to have simple logic at your
receiver and your sender.
So for your receiver, single SDK call,
your receiver just has
to either pull an event
for the native integration
or a simple API call.
So you don't have to build
a lot of error handling
and additional logic in your
producers and consumers.
And so that allows you to really,
really efficiently produce coupling.
In the Amazon world,
we're usually talking about EventBridge
when we're talking about this pattern.
So it's a serverless service,
has native integrations with
most of the things on AWS,
allows you to build global architectures
with global endpoints.
And so the EventBridge architecture starts
with defining some event sources.
So that could be an AWS
service, your customer events.
In our case, a lot of customer events.
Those then go to a number of buses.
So a default event bus,
a customer event bus,
depending on whether it's an
AWS event or your own event.
And then we have these rules.
So a rule is the way that
we then map those events
into the downstream services.
So the first thing I'm gonna
do is define what is an event.
So this is one of the things that we have
to be really deliberate about
when we're building
event-driven architectures.
So we go sort of one step deeper
than something happens and we react.
Something happens in the past.
So we emit a signal
that state has changed.
So an order has been
created, an order was created
or a channel was created
or the lights switched off.
We can't change it.
So we can't unswitch off the lights.
We have to submit a new event that says,
"Hey, lights are switched on."
And these events act as this contract
between our producers and our consumers.
In EventBridge world,
that's a piece of JSON.
And an EventBridge rule is pretty simple.
So we've got a bit of
JSON, which is our event.
That's our, our producer
has admitted that event.
And our rule has another
bit of JSON which says,
"Hey, our source is com.flix.
Our region is Australia and New Zealand."
And we wanna get all of those events
and pass them to a particular consumer.
They've matched. That's great.
And so those consumers
can be a whole bunch
of different patterns.
So we can point to Lambda
and lots of event-driven
architectures are built
with Lambda.
But we can also send that to Amazon ECS
as we discussed earlier.
You can also talk to API destinations,
and that's a really, really
powerful feature of EventBridge,
and Eric is gonna go into some detail
around the nuances of that shortly,
and a whole bunch of other services.
However, this is not the
only pattern we've got
for event routers.
We've also got topics.
Topics are a subtly different
form of event router.
Here, we can broadcast
to multiple consumers.
We still can filter
consumers at the topic.
However, this is really
powerful for scaling out
to lots and lots of consumers.
We can support multiple protocols,
things like SNS, SMS, push certifications.
We also have options to maintain order
with first in, first out topics.
And so fully managed service
for doing this in AWS is SNS,
allows you to send nearly
unlimited messages per second.
And it says that in our
documentation nearly unlimited.
And so we're kind of serious about it.
You can, it's very, very difficult
to put any strain on the SNS service.
And you can send out to
12.5 million subscriptions
on each individual topic.
So if you've got a fan out
and you wanna send codes
or messages to everybody,
that's really, really powerful.
So it talks about routers.
Our next kind of category
of things are event stores.
So an event store allows our receiver
to process events in batches
and control how it's doing processing.
So it can control its order,
it can configure its own retry,
it can configure its
own dead letter queue.
Now, one of the important
things about a queue is only one
receiver can process a message.
That's a one-to-one integration
rather than a one to many integration.
You can manage that ordering,
but it's typically not
used as the backbone
of our event-driven architecture
because of that one-to-one pattern.
It's used more as just kind of some
of the sub patterns
we're gonna think about.
In AWS, the main service
we're doing that is SQS.
It's another one where
they docs say we scale
nearly infinitely, super easy to use.
Simple API, dead-letter queues,
first in, first out, all the
kind of features we expect.
We also support some of
the open source services.
So things like Amazon MQ,
which supports RabbitMQ or ActiveMQ.
So if you are using
some kind of integration
with existing open source stuff,
definitely a sensible option
and supports many of the same
patterns that you'd be using.
And then the third and final big bucket
of brokers we can think about are streams.
So streams are subtly different.
Again, here, we can do one for many.
So we can send messages
to multiple consumers.
However, all the consumers on,
that are reading a stream are
gonna get all the messages.
So the consumer itself has
to manage the filtering.
You've got ordering
enforced in the stream.
But again, the consumers
have to manage their own kind
of error handling and processing
to ensure that that ordering is enforced.
Really, really powerful service,
particularly if you're
doing really, really large
throughput of messages.
And so we've got Amazon Kinesis
as an AWS native version
of dealing with streams.
You could do gigabits
per second of streaming,
all the kind of integrations
that we talked about
with native integrations.
And the big player in the
open source space here is MSK
or is Kafka.
So Apache Kafka, absolute huge project,
really, really powerful streaming solution
which has loads of open
source integrations
and used for lots of venture
driven architectures.
Our managed service for that is MSK.
So you can use all the
kind of Kafka goodness
and get lots of the
management done by AWS.
So we've now got this
kind of box of toolkits,
we've got some compute,
we've got some routers,
and we've got all these kind of services.
And, you know, really, really easy
to start putting some of those
services into our diagrams
and starting building
things with these things,
particularly where you to
set up a EventBridge bus,
you know, a few lines of code,
a few lines of SAM or CDK or Terraform,
and you can be up and running.
But they're actually, you know,
they're very, very powerful.
There's a lot of places you can go wrong.
So the kind of, the meat
of what we wanna do is
how do we turn all these Lego bricks,
all of these different building
blocks into useful things
that we can build.
So Eric, I think you're gonna talk to us
about some of the patterns we can apply.
- All right.
So we've talked to you about, you know,
what is EDA, what are
the, obviously, all the,
and for those of you here in
America, routers is routers.
So just throw that out there.
I know some of you're like,
"Well, I don't even
know what a router is."
But it's a router, so I got you.
Yeah, I got you.
So, all right.
So we're gonna talk about
what are these patterns?
How do we apply this to ECS?
How do we make that work, right?
So let's jump in.
And we're gonna talk about
long running containers, right?
And this is kinda those services
that Matt was talking about earlier.
And so this is like, it's a push or pull.
It's kind of an end to end, right?
It is, "How many do you wanna send,
how many do you wanna process?" Okay?
So a traditional long
running container looks
something like this, right?
You have an ECS, you get
many different type of tasks
with different containers running in that.
You know, a lot of ECS users in there.
I don't really need to
probably teach you about that.
And of course, you have
your capacity providers
with our new, again, the managed instance,
which is super cool.
You could do a lot with that.
So I wanna show you,
we're gonna go through
some different patterns,
and the first pattern is
probably the most simple, right?
And this is a very common pattern.
Pattern number one is the public API.
Now, what this usually is, is
you're gonna have some type
of consumer or producer,
I'm sorry, producer pushing
data to a consumer, right?
And it's gonna go through an API.
So it's somewhere another machine,
they've got a signed, you know, URL
or they've got something,
and they're pushing to this data.
But your consumer,
even though you're running this
container, maybe it doesn't,
you know, again, we have that 1988 code
and it's not ready to handle all that.
So how do we put a broker
in something like this?
Well, EventBridge is
where I generally start.
This is a really good way to say,
"Events coming in and I'm gonna send those
and then I'll push them
on to the container
through the API."
And how that works is the
producer's gonna send directly
into the EventBridge using
IAM, IAM, that's a hard one,
IAM role, it has permissions to do that.
It's gonna push data into the EventBridge.
And EventBridge is gonna
to use this API destination
to make a secure connection
to the API and drop data into,
or drop events into that, the consumer
and it can run however many we need to.
And we can kind of control
that through EventBridge
on how many are we sending
different things, like that.
Now, you may say, "Eric, that's great,
but not all of us are doing
machine to machine, right?
What if it's clients?"
It's all right, I got you.
So you can actually do something like this
where you can say,
"Okay, I'm gonna have an
authenticated user send data
to API gateway."
Let's say they're sending,
I don't know, analytics
or something like that.
And then I'm gonna use,
anybody familiar with a VTL?
Okay. Do you love it?
Yeah, I know exactly.
He's like, "I want to
tackle you for saying it."
So VTL is Apache Velocity
Template Language,
and it runs at API gateway.
And you can actually transform
a request come from a user
and put it right onto EventBridge.
And I've got some examples out in the wild
of how to do that.
But this allows you a secure access
where they can continue to push that,
and I don't have to run a
Lambda function in between,
and I can still get data to the container.
So this is pattern number one.
- [Matt] And writing a
VTL is is no fun at all,
if anyone's tried it.
But Kiro is really good
at writing VTL code.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Matt] A couple of prompts
and you'll have something
working really, really quickly.
- Yeah, VTL is back because of Kiro,
and it's Velocity Templating
Language by the way.
I'm just proud I know that.
So there you go.
All right, so the second
pattern looks a whole lot
like the first because
it really is, right?
And so what we're doing
here is we have this ability
in EventBridge with the,
and we announced this last year
with PrivateLink and VPC Lattice,
you can actually connect to
private endpoints, right?
So this is super helpful if you have to,
"Look, I need to throttle how
much is getting in there."
So let's go ahead and drop
event data into EventBridge
and then we'll use the
private endpoint connection.
And now, we've done that.
So those are the first two patterns,
again, kind of starting easy
and we'll climb up there, right?
So the next pattern we're
gonna do is what we call point
to point, right?
And so this looks pretty simple,
but what we're doing here
is we have ECS containers
that poll for events.
So instead of things getting
pushed to ECS container,
it's gonna actually
pull data off the queue.
And so you manage the
rate limit in the code.
You can say, "Grab 10, grab 20."
But you can also do some of
that, you know, the window
and control on SQS as well.
And your retry and failure are
managed at the queue as well.
So if something doesn't happen,
you get a retry out of that.
And so this gives you a lot of control
and downstream protection, right?
Now, when you're running queues,
the polling patterns, it
looks kinda like this.
It'll basically take,
let's say you have six.
So I'll grab six off there
and my different tasks will handle that,
kinda like Matt was showing
how the queues work on that.
And then, so how SQS works,
if you're not familiar,
is when a task is grabbed,
it doesn't actually
disappear out of queue.
It's made invisible.
It's magic.
It's the invisible queue
or the invisible event.
And after a certain amount of time,
if the consumer hasn't said,
"Yep, I took care of it,"
then it's made visible again
and it can be redone, right?
So this works really well
when you have, you know,
your traffic's metered
and you can do that.
However, what if your traffic
is unpredictable, right?
It's like, "Oh, I'm starting,
I get a lot of traffic
and then I get a little bit of traffic.
and then I get a lot of traffic."
And it goes up and down like that.
Well, that's all right.
We can handle things like that
through what we call predefined metrics
or through autoscaling, right?
So with autoscaling, we're actually able
to do step scaling on SQS
using the message count.
So we look at the message count
and how do we step that up
to handle the autoscaling
and how to bring it back down.
In this particular example,
I'm doing plus one task at
five messages, plus two at 15.
So it's watching that
and it's going up as need
be and it's coming down.
And then we put in a
cool down of 300 seconds.
So we don't,
what you don't want is your
autoscaling doing this, right?
You want it doing this.
How relaxing was that?
That was cool, all right.
I feel good, all right.
So you wanna do that.
So that's why we put in that cool down.
And then you get multi-period evaluation.
So we're looking over,
we're not just looking
at one and reacting one
and reacting one and reacting.
It's looking, "Okay, how's
the scope look?" Right?
So this works really well
for a lot of your traffic.
So you use these predefined
metrics, and there you go.
However, not all traffic is
the same size, the same shape.
Traffic looks very different, right?
I don't know about y'all,
but you never know,
"Am I processing a two-minute video?
Am I processing a two-day video?"
You know, those kinds of things.
So what if this looks really big
and your size is not consistent?
How do you do that?
Are these predefined metrics gonna work?
Probably not.
So then we get into custom metric math.
Now, I've never been great at math.
I'm not gonna lie.
I can only count to two.
All right, some of you're awake.
I can actually, here's the truth,
I can get to four if I take my shoes off,
but that gets weird for everybody.
So we'll go with two, right?
So the idea here is we're
gonna use custom metric math
and we're gonna combine
some metrics, right?
So we're gonna do metric messages divided
by the running tasks.
We looked at the pack log per task.
And we're gonna go for target value
of acceptable latency divided
by processing time, right?
So we're looking at some different things.
And then we set this up,
we still do our cool down.
So we're not, you know,
reacting really fast.
And we prevent division.
You can see I've got some code in there
by doing a max function.
So you prevent division by zero.
And so this allows us to do
some mathematical equations.
I'm saying all kinds of big words.
Some math to figure out
how we're gonna do it.
But not just one metric.
You're using multiple metrics to do this.
And so this is an idea of
how that policy would look
and how you set that up.
- [Matt] Well, well done Eric.
- Thank you.
- [Matt] I've been
watching Eric rehearse that
for the last two weeks and
trying to get his maths out, so.
- I can't do math to save my life.
- Make it for it.
- Like, okay, I don't know how to do this.
So, Matt's been tense
up till that moment, so.
All right, thanks, buddy.
All right, so that's how you do that.
So when you're gonna do metrics,
don't just let your system run and go,
"Ah, I sure hope it makes it," right?
You have the story, you have
the observability to go,
"Okay, we can follow that."
That's really important.
Anytime you're doing anything
but really specific in EDA
'cause you can build really
optimized systems that work,
that run with your load
rather than just saying,
"All right, provision till, you know,
we can handle anything
and pay for that," right?
Okay.
So the next thing we're gonna get into
are what I call event-based containers.
Now, I haven't made
that a popular term yet,
but every re:Invent for
the last two re:Invents,
I've said this, "Someday
it's gonna stick."
I'm coining this.
Mark, I wanna see it in a blog.
So, all right.
So event based containers,
what I mean by this,
it's kinda like event-driven containers
but a little different.
And maybe I'll explain
that and maybe I'll forget.
But it's this idea of a one-to-one, right?
So one, and Matt explained it earlier
when we wanna run one
container for an event.
So what does that look like?
Well, so we got a producer
and we're gonna kick an
event into EventBridge.
Now, normally if I'm running
a container on Fargate,
I will have a service,
and that service will
have a task definition.
This will all be at the container level.
But now with this, I can
actually do the task definition
at EventBridge that actually
will come with the event.
I can say, "Hey, here's a
definition, here's an event.
Do your thing," right?
Now, I'm not gonna get any data back.
I'm just gonna get a simple,
it's basically a fire and forget.
But that works for a lot
of what we're doing, right?
So your producer's gonna
kick a single event out
that EventBridge is gonna take that,
it's gonna send the task
to, calls the RunTask API,
and it's going to run that.
And you get one task versus to one event.
And actually, it's not
necessarily one container.
You wanna look at it, it
could be multiple containers
'cause you might have multiple tasks,
sidecars, things like that, all right?
So this is the pattern four,
this is the EventBridge pattern.
This is very popular.
And this is really, you
don't wanna use this
for dump a million events into EventBridge
and bring up a million containers.
That's not how, the RunTask
API will get overrun.
It's not designed for that.
You wanna do this.
We actually built this
exact example here a couple
of years ago,
we were doing video
processing and serverless
'cause it can be done.
And we were running video processing
and we would say, "Okay,
if the video has these,"
maybe file size or time limit
'cause we had the metadata.
If it's under two minutes,
process it in a Lambda file
because that's all we need.
If it's over two minutes,
spin up a container.
Most of our videos were under two minutes,
but every once in a while,
we had those one-offs, right?
So this is a really good
example on doing that.
We could do rules for that to set it up.
All right, so the second one
looks somewhat like this.
Pattern five is step functions.
Who uses step functions today?
Oh, do I love step functions.
I'm a step functions nerd.
I believe step functions first
and I'm super excited about it.
So step functions can
work much like EventBridge
in that it can actually
have the task definition
and you send that to EventBridge,
but it gives you a little
bit more flexibility.
It gives you synchronous, synchronous,
synchronous and asynchronous options.
Now, that means blocking
and non-blocking, right?
So let me show you how
this can work, okay?
So the async pattern,
this is the first one we're gonna do.
And this is kind of a fire and
forget just like EventBridge.
So what we do is we use a run task.
And so we do, it's an async,
it's a fire and forget.
And it returns of
acknowledgement of the request.
"Yes, I got your request,
I'm working on it."
Move on.
And the task, the step
function will actually move on
from this point.
It won't wait.
You don't get any data back, off you go.
However, sometimes there are times
when you need to stop and wait.
You need to know that that
was successful or failed.
So we also offer what we
call the dot sync pattern.
This is kind of cool.
Not kind of, it's really cool
because it handles the
polling for you, right?
So what happens is when it sends,
it sends to the RunTask API
and then it pulls the describe
ECS task for a status.
If it worked, then you get a 200 back.
If it failed, then you get a 400 or a 500
or whatever going on, right?
And so, however, you still don't
get data back from the ECS,
and a lot of times this is okay.
But this is an, if I
need to poll services,
and this happens a lot, okay?
But you may say, "Eric,
yeah, we need data back.
How do I do that?"
Well, let me show you.
So next pattern we're
gonna talk about this
is the callback pattern using the token
and send task completion.
Anybody use this now?
All right, a couple of you, okay.
Anybody like, "Wow."
Well, I haven't explained it yet.
Let's wait on that question.
All right, I will get a wow out of here.
All right, so the way this
works is when you come
to this task, it's gonna generate a token
and it's gonna send
that token with the data
and the task definition to the RunTask API
and it's going to bring
the task up, right?
And then it's gonna give all
that data to the container
and the container will turn
on, and it'll sit and wait.
And it'll wait for that task to be done.
So in the container,
when the job's all done,
you actually call the service.
There's an API endpoint
send success or send fail.
And you call it with the callback token
and step functions goes,
"Oh, I know which workflow
that is based on your token.
Here you go, success or fail.
And here's the return data."
Okay, so you're able to get
data back to the step function
and modify and work on that later.
So this is a very, very
powerful event-driven model
that you can do in step functions, right?
Okay, so then the task needs
to invoke step functions.
And the API goes to
complete, and off you go.
Now, there's one more
pattern I wanna show you
that I'm gonna be really honest.
I just learned about last year,
and I think is super cool.
And I think you're fairly,
you just learned about.
- [Matt] I learned about
this in practicing,
when you talked about it a
few months ago, Eric, so.
- Is anybody using
activities in step functions?
Okay, anybody heard of
activities step functions?
Okay, one person, but
he knows VTL too, so.
(audience laughing)
He's kind of a nerd.
All right, so let me tell
you about activities.
So here's how activities work.
When you create, you go into the console,
you can do it through the API,
but you actually create an activity
outside your step function.
It sits on its own.
So you create this activity.
What happens is step functions
creates a managed SQS queue,
and it's gonna manage it for you
and handle all that stuff, right?
So then what you do is
from your step functions,
and not just one of them,
but any of them, you
can pump data into the,
or pump events into this activity queue.
And then you have a pool of ECS workers.
Eh, we're tying ECS in here.
This pool of workers then,
much like any other pattern we've seen,
polls for this data, does the work.
It's got the same kind
of interaction as SQS
'cause it's an SQS queue
and then sends back to step functions
with the task token and the data.
And now, you've sent,
you're handling tons.
This is when you have,
"I have thousands upon thousands
upon thousands of events
and I need them to be processed
from multiple workflows."
This is the pattern for this.
Now, we talked about this last year
in this very session actually.
And I will tell you
this stuff really works.
Don't just take my word for it.
This tweet came out in September.
It says, "A few months back,
inspired by a great session by @edjgeek."
That's all I wanted to read.
No, I'm just kidding. Let's go on.
"We made changes to an AWS step
functions reducing its costs
from $450 per invocation to $1.
If you're intrigued, check it out
and I'll post that in the resources."
But, and you can find it.
Now, the first question is,
"Oh my gosh, what are they doing
that costs $450 per invocation?"
Right?
But they were doing a lot of
work, a lot of transitions,
hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds
of like minuscule micro transitions
that probably made more sense to run
in an ECS cluster, right?
So this activities
pattern handled that form.
All right, so activities
gives you several benefits.
First of all, managed queue.
You get one year retention in that.
Second connects on-premise.
This is where, "Oh, hey,
I need to process this
with on-premise stuff."
You can do that from there.
And finally, loosely coupled architecture,
and flexibility to use Spot,
which is a lot of people
don't think about this.
But if I'm using clustered
ECS, I can use Spot for that.
All right, so let's talk about
how does this help Sarah?
Sarah was in trouble. Let's show her.
- So now, we've got a whole set of tools
that we can combine with
our recess architecture.
We've got all of our different
brokers that we can apply.
We've got all of these different patterns
that we can apply to our architecture.
So what does that actually look like?
We talked before we are
relatively sensibly designed
microservices architecture, containerized.
The first thing we can do is
start publishing some events.
So we've got our order service.
Every time an order is created,
we can go into create
an order created event.
We can make a single STK call.
That's gonna publish it to EventBridge.
We now want to go and do
something with that event.
So maybe we want to take
out our payment service
that is currently happening synchronously,
but depends on some third party APIs.
We wanna go and make that asynchronous.
So we accept the transaction.
We use some validation
on the payment details.
We assume that our payment
process is gonna process it.
And if there's a problem down the road,
we can actually go and send
the customer a message and say,
"Hey, can you come and retry
with some new payment details?"
We can do that with our existing service
by having a rule that's
got that API integration.
We can do a private API integration
into our VPC using all the
stuff that Eric showed.
So pretty quickly, we can
take two synchronous services
and break them up using a
really, really simple pattern
and make them asynchronous.
We also want to go and
send a bunch of messages
to our customers.
So instead of having a direct SDK call
to one of the messaging
services inside our code,
maybe doing it synchronously,
we can break that out.
So we'll have a separate rule
that's looking at those orders
and sending you an SMS message saying,
"Hey, your order has been confirmed."
Or, "Actually, you need to go
and update your payment details."
We've got our loyalty service.
So a year ago, this is
the service that blew up.
We've got a third party service
that we were expecting
to respond immediately.
Now, it's important that our
customers receive loyalty
points when they make a purchase,
but it probably doesn't
have to happen immediately
as part of that flow.
In fact, we'll probably happy
if it happens some point
before the end of the month.
Here, we can send all of those
orders of the order details
into a queue,
and that loyalty service can
process them on their own time.
We don't need to scale out that service.
It can just tug away
and make sure it's kind of
catching up with that queue.
And then finally,
we've got this really
cool activity pattern
that Eric taught us about.
Once a month, we want
to go and run a process
that's gonna look at all
of our customers sales
and loyalty points and tier changes
and do a whole bunch of processing
and go and send them some
personalized discounts
to help them, encourage them to come back
and buy some more stuff.
So here, we can use step
functions and activity pattern
and we can actually do
that batch processing
in a really, really
efficient event-driven way.
So we can keep applying these patterns
in different ways to our architecture.
EventBridge at the heart of
it, using ECS for our compute.
And quite quickly get to a new solution.
So next year in November
when things ramp up,
Sarah sits at her desk
and nothing happens,
and boss is happy.
Everyone gets to celebrate.
Go, Sarah, we're happy for you.
- That's right.
So Sarah's happy.
She's now EDA partially
and she's moved part of it.
She's a good part of it
and she can do a lot more.
So here's what we wanna help you with
when you walk away from here.
If you're not doing EDA now,
it's not a flip of a switch, right?
I love this statement.
Werner Vogels, VP and CTO at Amazon says,
"Systems that don't evolve will die."
He's also the one that says,
"Everything breaks all the time," right?
Two very known quotes.
So it's important that we evolve.
If your system is good enough,
it probably won't be soon.
You always wanna be watching.
Even if it's working, is
it working efficiently?
Is it saving you money?
So one thing we encourage
when you're looking
on your EDA journey is where do you start?
Well, you may not have full understanding.
EDA, like anything else,
you learn as you go.
So I encourage you start small,
start with, you know, an implementation
that you can start working on,
and your understanding
will grow with that.
Obviously, don't start in production,
just hopefully you know that
already, but there it is.
And, but as you grow with that,
you know, you can, you
learn more and you go.
So here's some key
takeaways I would give you.
Synchronous microservices
crack under pressure,
you learn that.
Sarah didn't fail because of ECS.
She failed because the tight
coupling, things like that.
EDA is the ultimate decoupling
superpower. It really is.
It allows you to really build
that scale and reliability.
ECS plus Fargate brings the muscle.
Service containers,
zero servers to manage,
instance scale, things like that.
And you've got routing options for days.
This can give you a lot
of flexibility to do that.
ECS runs every EDA pattern
like a champ, right?
So we just talked about push,
pull, sync, async, callbacks.
Autoscaling becomes your superpower.
ECS Managed Instances equals less hops.
So you're gonna be able to,
obviously, we talked about
the managed instances,
how those are gonna help.
And step functions unlock
next level orchestration.
So you're able to do a lot
of orchestration on that.
And finally, loosely coupled systems.
And yes, Sarah does win
by running this route.
We promised you some resources.
I encourage you to check
these out, s12d.com/CNS307-25.
All right, here's a couple
other resources I'm gonna give
you here.
Let me go back.
I saw some of you still
trying to get that,
so let me throw that up here for a moment.
All right.
And then the next thing I'll tell you
is we've got a couple other
resources I would encourage you
to check out.
I tried to get ones after this,
but the best practices
for service developers,
super strong session.
This is a great one.
API207: Using event-driven architectures
to modernize legacy, more EDA.
And then serverless
espresso is a great example
of event-driven application at scale.
You get the coffee in the expo hall
or the certification lounge,
and then go see how it was built.
I really encourage you to do that.
If you wanna learn more about serverless
and application integration resources,
we have a lot out there.
On behalf of Matt and myself,
I really wanna tell you.
Thank you, Matt.
You have anything else you wanna
throw out, shameless plugs?
- If you can make it to
the Mandalay Bay at 5:30,
we'll be doing a chalk talk,
diving into a lot of these
patterns in more detail
and really helping unpick
them with the audience.
I think that's the last one.
- All right.
And for my shameless plug is on Wednesday,
I'll be discussing at 10:30,
and I can't mention
what that is right now,
but I encourage you to keep
10:30, Mandalay Bay open.
If you love serverless,
you'll love me for this.
So that's all I can say.
I wish I could say more, but
I encourage you to do that.
With that, I wanna say
thank you very much.
Please fill out the survey, let us know.
We always like to know
how we can do better.
Enjoy re:Invent.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)